MALE SPEAKER: All right, Joanna.
Let's write down everything
about Android layouts.
So to summarize, a view
group is just a fancy name
for a layout-- a view
you can add children to.
JOANNA: Exactly.
And we actually have all
of these different layouts
to choose from, because they are
functionally different in how
they lay their children out.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
Like linear layout is
always one row or one
column, while frame layout
can have overlapping children.
JOANNA: Exactly.
But if you want to
kind of influence
that overlapping or
that column, that's
when you want to use
a layout attribute.
This is what clarifies
to the system
where these children should be.
Like, look at frame layout.
We have layout gravity
specifying on both children,
but in different ways
so that they overlap.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh.
So this layout width
and height that I've
been adding to children
along are actually
rules for the parent,
not for the view itself.
JOANNA: Thankfully,
we make it really easy
for you to understand
in the blog post linked
in the description
below, because we're
going to talk you through every
layout attribute you should
know about and whether
or not that layout
is really right for your app.
MALE SPEAKER:
Sounds really long.
JOANNA: Just a bit.
Anyway, it's a great
resource, so check it out.
It's going to help
you build better apps.
MALE SPEAKER: Build better apps.
Build better apps.
JOANNA: Stop.
[MUSIC PLAYING]